I'm going to talk about the strategizing
brain we're going to use a unusual
combination of tools from game theory
and neuroscience to understand how
people interact socially when value is
on the line so a game theory is a branch
of original applied mathematics used
mostly in economics political science a
little bit in biology that gives us a
mathematical taxonomy of social life and
it predicts what people are likely to do
and believe others will do in cases
where everyone's actions affect everyone
else that's a lot of things competition
cooperation bargaining games like
hide-and-seek and poker here's a simple
game to get us started everyone chooses
a number from 0 to 100 we're going to
compute the average of those numbers and
whoever's closer to two-thirds of the
average wins a fixed prize so you want
to be a little bit below the average
number but not too far below and
everyone else wants to be a little bit
below the average number as well think
about you want what you might pick as
you're thinking this is a toy model of
something like selling in the stock
market during a rising market right you
don't want to so early because you miss
out on profits but you want to sell wait
wait too late to win everyone else sells
triggering your crash you want to be a
little bit ahead of the competition but
not too far ahead
ok here's two theories about how people
might think about this then we'll see
some data some of these will sound
familiar because you probably are
thinking that way I'm using my brain
theory to see a lot of people say I
really don't know what people are gonna
pick so I think the average will be 50
they're not being strategic at all and
I'll pick two-thirds of 50 that's 33
that's the start other people are a
little more sophisticated using more
working memory say I think people will
pick 33 because they're gonna pick a
response to 50 and so I'll pick 22 which
is 2/3 of 33 they're doing one extra
step of thinking two steps that's better
and of course in principle you could do
three four or more but it starts to get
very difficult just like in language and
other domains we know that it's hard for
people to parse very complex sentences
with a kind of recursive structure this
is called the cognitive hierarchy theory
by the way of something I've worked on a
few other people and it indicates that
kind of hierarchy and along with some
assumptions about how many people stop
at different steps and how the steps to
thinking are affected by lots of
interesting variables
Varian people as we'll see in a minute a
very different theory a much more
popular one and our older one due
largely to John Nash of a Beautiful Mind
Fame is what's called equilibrium
analysis so if you've ever taken a game
theory course at any level you will have
learned a little bit about this and
equilibrium as a mathematical state in
which everybody has figured out exactly
what everyone else will do
it's a very useful concept but
behaviorally it may not exactly explain
what people do the first time they play
these types of economic games or in
situations in the outside world in this
case the equilibria makes a very bold
prediction which is everyone wants to be
below everyone else therefore don't play
zero let's see what happens this is this
experiments been done many many times
some of the earliest ones were done in
the 90s by me and Rosemarie Nagel and
others this is a beautiful data set of
9000 people who wrote into three
newspapers and magazines that had a
contest the contest had send in your
numbers and whoever is close to
two-thirds of the average will win a big
prize
and as you can see there's so much data
here you can see the spikes very visibly
there's a spike at 33 those are people
doing one step there is another spike
visible at 22 I noticed by the way that
most people pick numbers right around
that they don't necessary key executive
Ike than they did there's another group
of people who seem to have a firm grip
on equilibrium analysis because they're
picking 0 or 1 but they lose right
because picking a number that that low
is actually a bad choice if other people
aren't doing that clearly analysis as
well so they're smart but poor where are
these things happening in the brain
one study by Corus le navel gives a
really sharp interesting answer so they
had people play this game while they
were being scanned in fMRI and to
conditions in some trials they're told
you're playing on another person who's
playing right now and we're going to
match up your behavior at the end and
pay you if you win and the other trials
they're told you're playing a computer
they're just choosing randomly so what
you see here is a subtraction of areas
in which there's more brain activity
when you're playing people compared to
playing the computer if you see activity
in some regions we've seen today medial
prefrontal cortex dorsal medial however
up here ventromedial prefrontal cortex
anterior cingulate an area that's
involved in lots of types of conflict
resolution like if you're playing Simon
Says and also they're right
left temporoparietal Junction wit and
these are all areas which are fairly
reliably known to be part of it but
what's called a theory of mind circuit
or mentalizing circuit that that is it's
a circuit that's used to imagine what
other people might do so it's this is
some of the first studies to see this
tied in to game theory what happens with
these one and two step types so we
classify people by what they picked and
then we look at the difference between
playing humans versus playing computers
which brain areas are differentially
active on the top you see the one step
players there's almost no difference the
reason is they're treating other people
like a computer and the brain is to the
bottom players you see all the activity
in dorsal medial PFC so we know that
those two step players are doing
something differently now if you were to
step back and say what can we do with
this information you might be able to
look at brain activity and say this
person's gonna be a good poker player or
this person's socially naive and we
might also be able to study things like
development of adolescent brains once we
have an idea of where the circuitry
exists okay get ready this I'm gonna say
I'm saving you some brain activity
because you don't need to use your hair
detector cells you should use those
cells to think carefully about this game
this is a bargaining game two players
who are being scanned using EEG
electrodes are gonna bargain over one to
six dollars if they can do it in ten
seconds they're gonna actually hearing
that money if 10 seconds goes by and
they haven't made a deal they get
nothing that's kind of a mistake
together the twist is that one player on
the left is informed about how much on
each trial there is they play lots of
trials with different amounts of each
time in this case they know there's four
dollars the uninformed player doesn't
know but they know that the informed
player knows so the other foreign
players challenge is to say is this guy
really being fair or are they giving me
a very low offer in order to get me to
think that there's only one or two
dollars available to split in which case
they might reject it and not come to a
deal so there's some tension here
between trying to get the most money but
trying to go the other player into
giving you more and the way they bargain
is to point on a number line that goes
from zero to six dollars and they're
bargaining over how much the uninformed
player gets and the uniform player is
gonna get the rest so this is like a
management labor negotiation in which
the workers don't know how much profits
the privately held company has right and
they they they want to maybe hold out
for more money but the company might
want to create the impression that
there's very little to split I'm giving
you the most that I can
first some behavior so a bunch of the
subject pairs they play face-to-face we
have some other data where they play
across computers that's an interesting
difference as you might imagine but a
bunch of the face to face pairs agree to
divide the money evenly every single
time boring it's just not interesting
early it's good for them they make a lot
of money but we're interested in can we
say something about when disagreements
occur versus don't occur so this is the
other group of subjects who often
disagree so they have a chance of they
bicker and disagree and end up with less
money they might be eligible to be on
Real Housewives the TV show okay you see
on the left when the amount to divide is
one two or three dollars they disagree
about half the time and when the amount
is four five six they agree quite often
this turns out to be something that's
predicted by a very complicated type of
game theory you should come to graduate
school at Cal Tech and learn about it's
a little too complicated explain right
now but it's the the theory tells you
that this shape kind of should occur
your intuition might tell you that too
now I'm going to show you the results
from the EEG recording very complicated
the right brain schematic is the
uninformed person and the left is the
informed remember that we scanned both
brains at the same time so we can ask
about you know time synced activity in
similar or different areas
simultaneously just like if you wanted
to study a conversation and you were
scanning two people talking to each
other you'd expect common activity of
language regions when they're actually
kind of listening and communicating so
the arrows connect regions that are
active at the same time and the
direction of the arrows flows from the
region that's active first in time and
the arrowhead goes to the region this
active later so in this case if you look
carefully most of the arrows flow from
right to left that is it looks as if the
uninformed brain activity is happening
kind of first and then it's that it's
followed by activity in the inform brain
and by the way these are these are
trials where their deals were made this
is from the first two seconds we haven't
finished analyzing this data so we're
still peeking in but the hope is that we
should we can say something in the first
couple of seconds about whether they'll
make a deal or not which could be very
useful in thinking about avoiding
litigation and ugly divorces and things
like that those are all cases in which a
lot of value is lost by delay and
strikes here's the case where the
disagreement
you can see it looks different than the
one before there's a lot more arrows
that means that the brains are kind of
synced up more closely in terms of
simultaneous activity and the arrows
flow clearly for left to right that is
the inform brain seems to be kind of
deciding we're probably not going to
make a deal here and then later there's
activity in the uninformed brain next
when I introduced to some relatives
their hairy smelly fast and strong you
might be thinking back to your last
Thanksgiving maybe if you had a
chimpanzee with you Charles Darwin and I
and you broke off in the family tree
from chimpanzees about 5 million years
ago they're still our closest unit of
kin
we share 98.8% of the genes we share
more genes with them as zebras do with
horses and they're also their closest
cousin they have more genetic relation
to us than two gorillas so how humans
and chimpanzees behave differently might
tell us a lot about brain evolution so
this is a amazing memory test from
Nagoya Japan primate researchers to do
what they've done a lot of this research
this goes back quite a ways they're
interested in working memory the chip is
going to see watch carefully they're
going to see 200 milliseconds exposure
that's fast that's eight movie frames of
numbers 1 2 3 4 5 then they disappear
and they're placed by square so they
have to press the squares that
correspond to the numbers from low to
high to get an Apple reward let's see
how we can do it
this is a young chimps the young ones
are better than the old ones just like
humans and they're highly experienced so
they've done this thousand thousands of
times obviously there's a big training
effect as you can imagine you can see
they're very blase and kind of evidence
not only can they do it very well they
do it you know it's sort of lazy way
right who thinks who thinks you could
beat the chimps wrong we could front
will try maybe I will try okay so the
next part of this study about a quick go
quickly through is based on an idea of
two robots Izawa he had a bold idea that
what's he called the cognitive frame of
hypothesis we know chimps are faster
stronger they're also very obsessed with
status his thought was maybe they've
preserved brain activities and they
practice them in development that are
really really important to them to
negotiate status and to win which is
something like strategic thinking during
competition so we're gonna check that
out by having the chimps actually play a
game by touching up a touch to touch
screens the chimps are actually
interacting with each other through the
computers they're gonna press left or
right one chimp is called a matcher they
win if they press left left like a hi a
seeker finding someone in hide-and-seek
or right right the mismatch wants to
mismatch they want to press the opposite
screen of the chimp and the rewards or
Apple Cube rewards so here's how game
theorists look at these data this is a
graph of the percentage of times the
matcher picked right on the x-axis and
the percentage of times they pick right
by the mismatch here on the y-axis okay
so a point here is the behavior by that
a pair of players one trying to match
one trying to mismatch the an e square
in the middle actually any CHT qre those
are three different theories of Nash
equilibrium and others tells you what
the theory predicts is that they should
match 50/50 because if you match but if
you play left too much for example I can
exploit that if I'm the mismatch or by
then playing right and as you can see
the chimps each chimp is one triangle
are kind of circled around hovering
around that prediction now we move the
payoffs we're actually gonna make the
left left pal for the match or a little
bit higher now they get three Apple
cubes game theoretically that should
actually make the mismatches behavior
shift because what happens is the
mismatch will think oh this guy's going
to go for the big reward and so I'm
going to go to the right
make sure he doesn't get it okay and as
you can see their behavior moves up in
the direction of this change in the Nash
equilibrium
finally we changed the pants one more
time now it's for Apple cubes and their
behavior again moves toward the Nash
equilibrium it's sprinkled around but if
you average the chimps out they're
really really close within point a1
they're actually closer than any species
we've observed what about people what
about humans you think you're smarter
than chimpanzee here's two human groups
in green and blue they're closer to 5050
they're not they're not responding to
payoffs as closely and also if you study
their learning in the game they aren't
as sensitive to previous rewards the
chimps are playing better than the
humans better in the sense of adhering
to game theory and these are two
different groups of humans from Japan
and Africa they replicate quite nicely
none of them are close to where the
chimps are okay so here's some things we
learned today people seem to do a
limited amount of strategic thinking
using theory of mind with some
preliminary evidence from bargaining
that early warning signs on the brain
might be used to predict whether
there'll be a bad disagreement that
costs money and chips are better
competitors than humans as judged by
game theory thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you